congratulations on this movie it is dark
it is beautiful
um you were filming this though just as
the pandemic was unfolding toronto
started shutting down
what did that break of a couple months
do to you creatively when it comes to
this movie
we were able well we stopped for six
months and obviously we had to deal with
the notion of restarting because uh the
industry
uh the film industry in toronto is vital
and we didn't want to leave this just as
a pending thing
and uh
we we took the opportunity
uh
of being safe
within this pandemic and being
isolated with the material to refigure
reconfigure
how we saw the characters how we edited
the movie
what we had missed
what we were needed
it was almost like you had a second
chance
a second bite at the apple
uh when you came back and and we quite
literally there's a scene the lie
detector scene we stopped right in the
middle
and then when we came back for the rest
of the scene it was six months later
precisely in the same shot that we were
shooting so it was an
opportunity to
rethink
and re-evaluate
and i love this you know you have such
an amazing cast was it an immediate yes
from bradley cooper
yes
i mean in fact bradley
his life was very complicated
logistically because he was trying to
be bi-coastal for many reasons being in
los angeles and new york at the same
time i was figuring that out he he was
so complicated that he
everything in his life said look
don't take this right now but he he and
i connected
into the characters so strongly that he
he did it and it was quite immediate i
think it was the same day that we heard
back
and i love that ron pearlman kind of
brought this story to you almost 30
years ago and of course he had to be a
part of the movie i'm so glad he's in it
um do you remember what your early
conversations were with him about it
yeah ron was likening the character of
stanton to a character very famous in
american letters uh elmer gantry
you know he liked the idea of a hulkster
and a guy that saw the illusion
you know to people a populist
that that is always a very dangerous
discourse that
often every couple of decades or so
gains traction again you know so he
wanted to play that character
and i mean the sets are so beautiful
there's so much going on did you keep
anything for your cabinet of curiosities
yes i kept the the cyclops baby
i i myself bought
uh
for the movie i bought all the vending
machines that appeared in the movie i
bought them on ebay and i
rented them to the movie in exchange for
that baby
and i kept some of the furniture from
the hotel room that he lives in
with molly in buffalo new york
i knew you were going to say the baby so
that's perfect um
what are you so uh sorry what are you
just so excited that this movie is now
finally out and people are going to get
to see it
yes because uh look normally a movie
takes a year and a half
two years this movie has been over three
years in the making and it's it's uh i
mean i did bad
shape of water about four
years ago almost and
i'm ready i'm ready for it